[Musique]
bonsoir
qu'y a t'il nounours peas or j'entends
des bruits bizarres
je descends tout de suite on a besoin de
moi en bas de l'échelle
[Musique]
nicolas
chose à sa petite soeur non j'avais
raison
mais que se passe-t-il nicolas même
[Musique]
cette fille aux longs au long du calme
expliquez-vous gentiment
ne discutant pas moi je vais faire
maintenant
excellente idée pas preneur hutois
nicolas intulé mains propres j'ai
compris panda petit garçon cache ses
mains c'est parce qu'elles sont sales
mon petit nicolas allons un peu dans la
salle de bain
et m'avait la côte pour dormir et pour
d'année a baissé à mon petit frère non
non m avec un baiser je te dirai
bannissons non pauvres mais bon je te
dirai rien
merci gros nigaud
allons doucement
et suite main tons nude
nous allons voir ça
[Musique]
pimprenelle ce n'est pas bien mais c'est
pour rire ne tient pas rien pris et des
bonbons à toi ou sautille
et après bien pape rhône elle rend son
paquet de bonbons à nicolas
[Musique]
lg sous leur mort je lui réponds et en
paix tu viens de ne lui dira nicolas
allons donne moi ce paquet c'est moi qui
le cachent les où les petits garnements
et plus de disputes
ils ont leur peau ces bombes
à nounours il sauta nicole en scène qui
fait c'était pour moi je me méfie allons
embrasser vous et faites la paix
et en dormez-vous sagement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ni bonnes ni le petit
ado
[Musique]
le
alors le nours ce n'était rien de grave
patron une petite dispute me tout est
arrangé c'est très vilain la gourmandise
oh oui nounours allant en route
dany des enfants 1 demain
de boer
[Musique]